foreign
do you have a charm strategy that you
use in Plate Company with those that
hate your specific facts choice
I'm hoping to have fewer family
gatherings implode but not engagement
hasn't worked
um
you and I do
we do no strategy
yes
what is it
we refer to ourselves as dirty and
unvaccinated
and it
puts the people who are quietly thinking
that
in an awkward position because suddenly
they realize who in history they have
become yeah and and also that they're
seen right that's it
um so anyway I mean I would suggest
something like that right own it and at
the level that you can own it then
um it will put others at ease that
they're not quietly thinking about this
thing that you you know they know
they're dirty right
yeah so anyway yeah the charm goes a
long way and uh say dirty and
unvaccinated about yourself uh with a
smile on your face and see if it doesn't
lighten the mood
yeah
I wish I I wish I had something more but
no that is that is something we've both
done yeah seems to work
we've stopped hemorrhaging friends
that's nice you know
anybody
if the MRNA Vex causes the body to
produce Spike proteins
with the body eventually interpret the
protein as native and stop mitigating it
well that's uh that's what we have to
wonder about the igg4 result that we
talked about last week which I also
talked about with Joe Rogan
um this does look like an attenuation
signal
and uh I mean the real question is if
that's what it is yeah
so yeah
I didn't mean to interrupt no that was
pretty much what I had to say that's all
you got yeah yeah okay
um
Joe Rogan is a great interviewer who
occasionally steamrolls his guest on a
particular point I feel like we missed a
great opportunity to understand your
difference and opinion on forgiveness
vis-a-vis arguments surrounding vaccine
uptick uptake and reluctance yeah please
re-explain your argument and if you're
able Steel Man his
yeah okay
um
I'll steal me on his first Joe's point
is we have all been through some
terrible thing that was of none of our
choosing
and that
hate gets you nowhere
and
so we should just Embrace each other and
get over it
Joe I hope that was did you justice my
point to Joe
which is by the way a loser because it's
uglier but your point is a loser yeah my
point to Joe is look I'm
not all that interested in vengeance
I don't think you know if I could press
a button and I could get us to Truth and
Reconciliation where nobody was punished
that would be deeply unjust there are
some people who I believe knowingly did
wrong and should be punished but I would
gladly take that deal in a heartbeat
because I believe the most important
thing to come out of this is a complete
understanding of what happened and
complete understanding of what happened
not only means
how did our Public Health authorities uh
talk us into such dangerous stuff and
continue to push in that direction once
it was obvious that it was a mistake
right that's one level but there's also
another thing which is like
interpersonally for all of us right
think about the person in your life who
this caused the most trouble with right
the friend who just lost and are never
going to see again whatever what the
hell happened there right you both need
to know what happened there what
happened on their side that they
couldn't understand that you were making
sense what happened on your side you
need to know so my feeling is
um
I'm not even if uh I would be glad to
see bad people punished it doesn't get
me out of bed in the morning at all like
not at all however
point that it becomes obvious that you
[ __ ] up you need to stop doing it and
so I do not have any forgiveness at the
moment for people who are still doubling
down on the stuff that's putting people
in danger and
my argument is really simple
if you want to get to the world that we
have to get to
the best way to do it is to leave the
people who are still shooting at us
with an incentive to stop and the
incentive to stop is
stop doing that
own up to what you did
and then we can get past this until then
we're not past it right you're still
shooting and so my feeling is that Joe's
solution while it's definitely
Kinder in its own way results in more
destruction in the end
well and
you're well aware of the distinction but
I feel like you've slightly conflated
uh not being in a forgiving mood with
feeling vengeful
and those are not the same thing
uh I I agree you you are perhaps the
least vengeful person I've ever met you
don't you don't seem to have it
in you you're not you're not driven by
that
by anger by hatred
um
but that can be true and it is true for
you at the same time as you can say but
I'm not forgiving you you're still
shooting at me
or even I'm not forgiving you uh you
were still shooting at me until
yesterday and now you're pretending it
didn't happen yeah
and then now you're pretending it didn't
happen like I you and I are a little bit
different here but I get really stuck on
that don't
you don't get to pretend that you
weren't doing all of those things that
you were doing no
yep and that's that's also not you know
I have more vengefulness in me than you
do but I don't feel like that's that's a
quest for vengeance either it's a it's a
it's a record that's the word I've been
using is it's a reckoning right that um
actually you're not you're not
trustworthy
if you have been doing all of this for
years now and you stop
and then never another word is said
not trustworthy you'll do it again you
will do it again I I agree it needs to
be a way a reckoning
um uh by the people who have done such
who have behaved this way wherein they
go to their own selves their own Gods
whatever it is
and
achieve some sort of reconciliation
so that the rest of the world however
narrow our broad that might be for them
can see actually
there is now something in place that
will help prevent that error from
happening again
yeah I agree I think there's a missing
category right there's forgiveness I'm
not gonna forgive somebody if they
haven't even recognized what they did
right but
after forgiveness do I need them
punished not really and I don't actually
think it's all that healthy for us to be
focused on punishing people except for
the very the few Very Bad actors right
the few Very Bad actors are a real
problem at the end of this those people
and people like them need never to be
given power again period that does not
require them to be punished I'd be happy
enough for them to be punished if they
did this knowingly but
um the key thing from the point of view
of our Collective well-being at the end
of this is that the hidden stuff isn't
hidden anymore right this is this is why
what unfolded in South Africa unfolded
that way there was no way to put South
Africa right but there was a way to own
up to what it had been you're talking
about in the 90s yeah
that's where where the phrase truth and
well as far as I know that's where the
phrase Truth and Reconciliation comes
from and the point is that is an
alternative to Ventures right so anyway
Joe and I are very close together here
except that he does not in my opinion
the mistake that he makes is that he
does not leave an incentive for people
to actually face themselves in the
mirror and say I screwed up and my
feeling is that That's essential
yeah I hate that this is the word we use
in English for this but why would we
facilitate them weaseling
he's weaseling out yeah you don't like
that because you like weasels I love
weasels yeah me too yeah weasels aren't
Weasley I agree yeah yeah it's bad [ __ ]
crazy is what that is what are you doing
to the bats all right
[Music]